now we're going to discuss the second of
two popular ways to analyze circuits and
this one is called the the mesh current
method this is actually one of my
favorite there's a fun spot in here
where we make up currents flowing around
in circles inside the circuit and it's
interesting so in the mesh current
method what we do is we define mesh
currents so we need to define that word
a mesh current a mesh current is a
current that flows in a mesh and a mesh
is the open windows of a circuit here's
one of the meshes in our circuit there's
another mesh here it's an open window
and this third one here is another one
and this will be our mesh current number
one we'll call it eye one and we can
define these other mesh currents like
this and I'm going to define them all to
go around in the same direction they're
all going clockwise around our circuit
now let me take a second to label the
other components in our circuit here
we'll call this V we'll call this r1 r2
r3 r4 and this has a current source in
it we'll call that I that makes it a
little bit more interesting and this is
one of the reasons we use the mesh
current method the word mesh actually
comes from like screen doors or windows
screens where there's wires and there's
spaces between the wires so a space in a
wire network is called a mesh that's
where the name comes from these mesh
currents are kind of interesting the in
some sense they exist in but it doesn't
seem like they really do how could these
currents be flowing around in circles
let's look a little closer altijd source
V is equal to mesh current i1 and also
when we get up here to our one mesh
current i1 is flowing through r1 in this
direction here what happens when we get
to r2 we have one mesh current flowing
down through Arts
you and another mesh current flowing up
through our - how could this make sense
let me go over here and we'll draw
redraw our - here's our - and now I'll
redraw the the mesh current so here we
have a mesh Colonel I 1 going down like
that
and we have a mesh current I 2 like that
and I'll label on here I'll label the
element current for our - we'll call
that I our - now what's going to happen
this is a really wonderful application
of the principle of superposition I 1
and I 2 superimpose inside our - to
create IR - so if we want it to know ir
- it would be the sum of these two
currents now I 1 is flowing in the same
direction is IR 2 so this equals I 1 and
I 2 is going in the opposite direction
so it gets a minus sign and if we
somehow knew i1 and i2 this is how we
would compute the actual current that's
flowing in r2 so next since this is a
method I'm going to list out the steps
of the method the mesh current method is
the first thing is to draw the meshes
and we did that over here when we do I 1
I 2 and I 3 and the second step is to
solve the easy ones
well we say an easy one here's an
example of an easy one this the current
source I right here defines what I 3 is
so I 3 is an example of an easy current
to solve for and then the third step in
the method is to write kirchoff's
voltage law KVL write kirchoff's voltage
law equations for the two remaining mesh
currents and the fourth step is solve so
in this video we're going to do the
first three steps and in the next video
we'll do the full solve okay so let's
run our our mesh current method number
one draw the meshes here's step one
happening right here so we can check off
we did step one step two is solve for
the easy ones and we think I three
counts as an easy one i three flows down
through the current source and so step
number two so step two is I three equals
negative I because they're pointing in
opposite directions but that's it that's
the easy one we've done that now we get
to the next step so now let's start step
three we're going to write KVL equations
on each of these messages we'll start
here and we're going to go around this
mesh in this direction and write
kirchoff's voltage law so the first
thing we come to is a voltage rise we go
in the minus side out the plus that's a
voltage rise of V volts next we get to
r1 and r1 has a current flowing through
it a mesh current and it will have a
voltage on it like that because the
currents coming in from this side and
that will give us a voltage we go in the
plus out the minus so that's going to
give us a voltage drop of a drop
of r1 times i1 right now we are over to
here we go around the corner and we go
through r2 now r2 is odd because it has
I 1 and I 2 flowing into it so what are
we going to do
well we already figured out this element
current is written down right over here
there it is right there
so if I label the current going down
here I have a plus and a minus this is
going to be another voltage drop going
around the loop so it's going to have a
value of r2 times this value here I 1
minus I 2 and now we've made it all the
way back to home to the where we started
from and so that's our KVL equation
which we set equal to zero alright next
step let's do the other mesh we're going
to go start here and we're going to go
around this mesh in the same way first
the first term we're going to see a
voltage oh look it's a voltage rise so
we'll have a plus here a voltage rise
and it's the same term that we had in
the previous equation it'll be plus r2
times i1 minus i2 that's the voltage
rise going from here to here now we go
through r3 now r3 just has one mesh
current he just has I 2 flowing through
it so I can put that there so that
counts as a voltage drop it gets a minus
sign and its value is our 3 times i2
that's that one now we go over to our
for our 4 this is the same thing with
two currents that we had over here with
our 2 so we do the same thing again this
is going to be a will define this as a
voltage drop
there's the element current well and
it's the same form as we had here when
we calculated the current for r2 so this
is going to be a voltage drop gets a
minus sign and it's going to be our four
times
this time it's I two going down I 2
minus I 3 and did we get home now we're
all the way home
so our KVL equation is all that equal to
zero
so these are our two simultaneous
equations that represent our circuit and
we wrote them using the mesh current
method so we get to check off step three
and in the next video we'll solve these
two equations